ari
[Applause]
no
don't ari
no you're what'd you think of that i
mean we've had some incredible
performances tonight i don't know how
america is going to make this decision
no i mean that was are you are you out
of your mind
i'm sorry i'm sorry that's just the most
ridiculous thing i've ever seen
in my life
you're insane that right there is the
voice coach ariana grande having a bit
of a fit a laughing fit that is it's the
most fun i've ever had in my whole life
now what caused ari to laugh during the
show well it all started when contestant
wendy moton performed marvin gaye and
tammy terrell's you're all i need to get
by during the top eight live
performances
[Applause]
wendy's powerhouse voice left the
coaches speechless ari even bows down on
her knees
are we on tv america's gonna make the
decision is this and here's what they
gotta do if you want wendy in the finale
you can vote on nbc.com with the voice
official app
give it up
wendy moton
but this wasn't the only time the
position singer burst out into laughter
during the show
following singer paris winningham's
performance his coach blake shelton was
so moved he said this so
it
did exactly what you needed to do man
that fun side of your personality you're
so laid back and then so aggressive out
of nowhere and literally i i mean i
don't know about y'all but i i mean i'm
married
all right to gwen stefani but you made
you made me feel something just yeah i
was like hey
ari and fellow voice coach kelly
clarkson couldn't help but giggle over
the country star's reaction to paris's
stellar performance
my heart was pounding okay paris i said
it my heart was pounding for paris all
right i just said it
i just said it if you want paris in the
finale you can vote on nbc.com and not
just this episode but actually this
whole season of the voice has been
filled with laughter while recently
chatting with jimmy fallon on the
tonight show blake lovingly teased kelly
the only thing i worry about with that
particular group is they're on kelly's
team
and you know while kelly is a great
person and an incredible artist and a
great talk show host
she is hands down
the worst coach we've ever had on the
voice in 21 seasons of doing this
the worst but when the late-night tv
host disagreed blake changed his mind
out of everyone you've ever had
yeah more than adam
she is the second worst coach that we
have ever had
on this on this show for sure
without question
he and i fought the most in battles talk
about a friendly rivalry
and on jimmy's new game show that's my
jam ari kelly blake and john legend
playfully battled while trying to nail
the lyrics to taylor swift shake it off
and let's just say things didn't go so
hot for blake
[Applause]
and when e.t sat down with all four
coaches ahead of season 21 there were
plenty of giggles all around they're
very very generous and kind and not true
at all
even even blake didn't want to we always
come out like you know in like like i'll
go john goes whatever and blake's
usually lasts he gets the most screams
and and and well
and then he used to he used to do and
then all of a sudden he was like can
ariana go before me because they lose
their mind so it's embarrassing to
follow her but that's why we enjoy it
see we wanted it to stay that way
because we enjoyed the hearing problem
it exposes
my lack of
celebrity celebrities
when ariana goes in front of a celebrity
yeah i think i have a hearing problem
but they love her they love you but you
can answer it sorry no i was i mean i
yeah
i think i would just say that it's the
same answer for both it's just being new
there's so much to learn but i
feel like i just get to learn watching
them and it's been amazing so yes